Hi there!
Welcome to NERV?
We're a clandestine organization that answers directly to the UN.
The key in the effort to rebuild our world.
15 years ago in the second impact, half of the world's population was wiped out.
Now the Angels have returned.
There is little we can do to stop them.
With limited options, we had to find a new solution to protect our way of life.
You're looking at the most advanced weapon system ever developed by man...
...the synthetic humanoid Evangelion.
You will be the pilot.
There are others like you,...
...other Children burdened with the task of protecting our home...
...and saving mankind from the brink of extinction.
We are go for launch.
Evangelion Unit 01 move out!
The Evas can beat the Angels.
The fact that we are even here to see this means that mankind has a sliver of hope.
I want you to understand that you're not the only one risking your life in this fight.
We are all in this together.
Move, Shinji!